what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation I don't need to say
anything I did in the intro as I
normally do do I just leave a like
that's all we ask let's watch
update us on Santiago's undercover
prison operation yeah she has made
contact with Jimmy figgis sister but
it's slow going I hope she comes back
soon oh you missed her no I lost the key
to her apartment and I'm taking care of
her fish they're all dead already aren't
they yeah damn it laughs
I think it's time for me to call in a
favor from an old colleague at the
bureau Bob Anderson he once picked up a
penny off the street which he then
reported on his taxes sounds like a
barrel of laughs
we worked together back in the day and
really hit it off
we're going to be here a while would you
like to talk
I'd rather not agreed
you interrupt the comedy line again I
swear to God
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna flip this
you could save your oh I know who Dennis
is
until after the joke is done
good to see you and you apologies it's
inappropriate for me to partake in such
informal conversation in front of your
detectives it's all right I am equally
to blame oh my God
like the guy we're looking for was
wearing a ski mask and he's about 5 10
Caucasian he's got a big scar on his
right hand his name is Ryan Whelan you
think you could idea if you saw him oh
yeah I'd recognize that Scar from 20
miles away you must have fantastic
vision
[Music]
[Laughter]
how are things going with Maura well I'm
part of her crew but she still won't
talk about her past so
what kind of stuff do you used to do in
New York what would all the questions
Regis
we're going to hear about our adoption
any minute I thought you were doing
fertility treatments we are but it's not
going well the doctor said my sterility
is so aggressive it may have spread to
her okay oh my god oh I'm Charles it's
amazing
oh no all right
anyway uh Miss Cortez your vagina looks
great muzzle
fake and affair there's an article about
the 99s monthly crime rate those numbers
aren't supposed to be public until next
week Terry you're gonna have to be more
interesting if you want to get an oh
dang
presented those numbers in a morning
briefing but I can't imagine anyone
would be stupid enough to leak them
really Terence look how dumb they are
laughs
printer's fixed oh
oh dang wow look at that what a great
magazine sir if you're interested the
new issue of clown boobies just came in
I can unpack the box for you what
what is Peralta doing it appears to be
rifling through
clown boobies magazine uh what
here you go
oh
thank you so so much
no thank you not thank you at all you
dirt bag
why were you hugging him my last appeal
got denied so he was comforting me I
want to talk to him alone about
something medical or what did I tell you
about asking too many questions right
that's that thing you killed a bunch of
[ __ ] for
both of their thighs were completely
wiped I've never seen that before yeah
that's because he's guilty and we're
just sitting here watching him eat a
peach that's a nectarine it's either a
nectarine or a peach just right unknown
stone fruit
[Laughter]
break into the FBI and steal the file
don't be observed well I apologize for
the absurdity I see no absurdity
actually I think Peralta is right
let's plant a heist what yes
Bob
laughs
we will be represented by these things I
had in my pocket
all I had was lit my lint is round my
lint is approximately one centimeter in
diameter my lint is blue my lint is
oblong my land is
I could drop down into the archive room
and steal the file now you're gonna get
out I can do a pull-up Terry will teach
me
this whole area is video monitored by
this guard here what do you know about
them I heard him mention Sex and the
City then I will discuss both of those
shows with him
I have an idea on how to smuggle you in
but it'll be a tight fit I'm flexible I
do a lot of yoga you do yoga helps keep
me centered if you ask me about it again
I'll hunt you down and rip your face off
Memento does yoga
covers blown I don't know but just to be
safe let's review your backstory I went
to Yeshiva med school residency at Mount
Sinai my best friend is Jacob peralberg
and we share everything with each other
so Jewish we both know why I'm here we
do you're hot speeding a mile a minute
it's not because I'm nervous
Cortez says that you're sensitive I like
that oh
you knew it
oh my everything okay in here we're all
good he was just checking me out
um and I was
do you really think we would leak
information on purpose no we think
you're dumb dumbs and you did it by
accident oh well that's very possible
wait do either of you even know what our
arrest numbers were
12. no no
[Music]
come on man use your muscles
where's my muscles oh great why didn't I
think of that great advice Terry you
know what it's a pull-up there's not
much to coach here
what about Steve he thinks guys oh Steve
is nothing no one likes Steve
of nothing
okay
okay
that's like me doing hello oh she's
actually good Blair Underwood but she
settles for Steve oh but you do get it
sir see now you do
hey
Scully Rosa wow that is very impressive
good job can you do it without screaming
fry bub Lee and we're ready
let's break into the FBI no let's break
into the FBI let's break into the FBI
let's break into the FBI let's break
into the FBI I feel like I'm doing it
let's break into the let's break into
the FBI
well done yes memorize that number quite
a big package I got there oh I apologize
for the double entender I can be such a
Samantha really
you don't seem like a Samantha well I'm
actually a combination of all four
characters five if you count the city of
New York yes
another Sex in the City guilty as
charred Sex in the City everything was
going right for Carrie her face was on
every bus her column was the Talk of the
Town and she met everyone's favorite
Furniture maker 24. yeah that's funny
she flipped out when she bumped into the
big getting out of that cab with Natasha
whom he had married who can blame her
they really knew each other the best
episode that year was episode 6 entitled
are we slots
[Laughter]
I drew that
I hate big Carrie should have ended up
with Mikhail Baryshnikov what he slapped
her are you insane
oh
Mission compromised
got the file preparing for extraction
no screaming Peralta
[Music]
it's such a good job
did you ask me they never should have
made the movie Abu Dhabi Abu don't
bother
wow I'm gonna use that please do have a
nice day
I love the universal hatred of The
Second Sex in the City movie let me see
that envelope oh um actually I can't
show you that
I asked him to come down and mail that
I just need to put my return address on
it I know just where to put that oh
there's Samantha again
oh nicely done gentlemen it was a little
tense there
we did it
what I'm only human you can't always
expect me to be the coolest guy ever
coolest guy ever try telling that to
Alan Greenspan nice burn Bob
oh look on her face you could romance
her into talking but you shouldn't do
anything that you're not comfortable
with you see The Art of Seduction is all
about making people wait right Genevieve
and I often begin our lovemaking okay
okay please stop guard
[Laughter]
who is Genevieve no one
I'm a chiropractor and answer it answer
it I mean why don't we just stay in the
moment why are you such a slave to these
little answer the phone and put it on
speaker no
no hello honey
they're through you're gonna be
I mean
this is the wrong number don't call here
again you're dead
[Laughter]
I'm trying to find out who our leak is
what makes you so sure that there's a
leak it might have just been that the
reporter was really good at his job like
that hot blonde surfer yeah maybe you
leaked it excuse me you don't take your
job very seriously whoa first of all I
take my job very seriously that's why
I'm here right now helping you and I'm
the only one doing it now watch me walk
away
it's me
he quashed all FBI and NYPD operations
relating to figus drug running
kidnapping murder those are the best
crimes why would you quash them let's go
arrest that punk
he says Punk just like you what do you
think he learned it
Punk
somebody's been here look a body we got
a body damn it he's dead biggest got to
him wait a minute he's got a pulse no
wait that's my pulse no it's his pulse
no it's both her pulses he's alive I'm
alive we're all alive
it's like an interrogating when he wakes
up I'll keep you company why don't you
two go home and get some sleep good idea
sir we'll head to the bar get super
drunk and then head home and get some
sleep yeah good idea sir
turns out your sensitive doctor isn't
who he says he is what what do you mean
why because he's about to adopt a baby
with his chiropractor oh thank God
why can't I find a good man it could be
because you're in prison for murder no
that's not
all my brothers friends from the mom all
dogs too no never mind you Tony Soprano
tell me everything about them thanks
that would be nice
ah not a toucher totally get it I'll
keep my hands to myself I know who your
lake is what I looked up the reporter
who published the crime number it was
Terry
the arrest numbers are in the photo
clear as day I gotta take that picture
down Gina I am so sorry I blamed you and
I knew you would say something like that
so I went ahead and bought myself a cake
on your behalf
oh dang and this has been here for the
last half hour detective didn't even
notice it God I'm so sick of doing
everyone's job for them
Maura told me who Vegas has working for
him in the FBI yeah I already know who
he is because I just caught him special
agent Ryan Whelan also I did one full
pull-up I'm gonna be so Buff when you
get back cool babe did you get the other
guy what other guy someone named Bob
Anderson
[Music]
I had a feeling he was involved I should
have said it
I was working for figus what he must
have been the one who deleted all those
digital files
yeah
there you go oh thank you
dang come on Captain pick up pick up
don't answer that Raymond
and now I'm going to have to kill you
oh Bob
[Music]
[Laughter]
not great Bob
imagine that really funny
the second he wanted to pull off the
heist I was like I wonder what [ __ ]
should have said John you should [ __ ]
that everyone down let everyone down
with Greg's amazing prediction your
streak is broken
second he presented The Heist I was like
I don't know about this I don't know
about this out of character
yeah
man what can you do you know there's
always next week
no this is the definitive moment of the
channel
yeah serving us forever yep that was a
that was a funny funny episode took a
while to pick up some steam but I like I
like the ones I build like that
sometimes they're not all going to be a
left ride right after the gate
but who's your what's your guy's name
Dennis pimento Dennis Larry Adrian
pimento what's his name Dennis Haysbert
Dennis Haysbert
he's the All-State guy now
he was the 24 guy and he was the 24 guy
which they paid tribute to which was
awesome truly
yeah uh I like the two of them together
they do work off they do
they are both very very similar yeah
naturally yeah he's the perfect mirror
slash foil perfect casting Choice there
um it's always fun when they get all
genre heavy and do a heist I do get a
little tense around the uh
I don't know the actress's name the one
in prison who they're interrogating oh
Tony Soprano's sister
you know what I'm talking pig is Sister
figus figures yeah I do get tense around
her yeah did you manage to provide a
weird sense of tension here without it
uh losing its comedy sometimes it is
like ooh isn't it yeah the way they've
done the whole and the gradual nature of
Amy finally getting yeah the information
I thought was like actually kind of
gracefully done
from the past episode of this one and
the whole like rigmarole with Charles
and all that stuff like yeah I thought
they they did nicely to to bring up the
tension there and then to have it unify
the episodes like you technically have
two different situations going on two
different plot lines but they are still
there's three plot lines well yeah but
you have two that are for the same end
but they're ostensibly feel like two
separate plots at the time and then you
have the C plot which is just in the
office
but uh I don't know a c plot
thematically ties in with the other
plots truly
because this sting this this undercover
investigation is going to affect the
crime stats
no because it's about a leak and they
think there's a snitch and someone's a
traitor within the law enforcement
that is true that is a good connective
tissue it's thematically tied in they
wasted all that time looking for some
kind of silly statistics leak when they
should have been looking for the double
agent at the FBI
oh
since I told you to not interrupt the
punch line you've been acting really
weird
different person now G
Onna my humor and my articulation is
dissolved I've I took some time and
rewrote the programs while the episode
was going so now it's going to be a
whole new me
I'm here on out
I don't know you anymore I will not
speak during your punchline
laughs
not my punchlines the shows I spent
hours writing them to make us laugh I
know and I appreciate them for it they
don't get enough credit so Stephanie
Beatrice I mean they should they hurt
she might have had a bit of a dancing
background but holy [ __ ] is she flexible
yeah she is a she really does practice
yogurt every day you know I've always
thought she was so ugly like I've said
so many times here and she just got even
uglier yeah this episode it's hard to
watch really like wow
how repulsive she is it's just escalated
so much I know I've talked many times
it's about just how off-putting it is
that's right
um but this episode in particular just
made me go you're a disgusting human
being and I hate you and you're an
Abomination against the Catholic church
it's really Brave of them to put her on
National Television like that where like
anybody could tune in and just like see
her you know yeah so it takes a lot of
guts
and there's a reason why you know Fox 11
doesn't exert Fox doesn't exist anymore
this is an NBC show I don't know which
network it is it doesn't matter look
either way they're brazen
like I said you've changed that's right
I just don't know my networks anymore
cut off one punch line yeah
and now I can't even make my own punch
like
no but I don't want to get near a
punchline anymore not for me all set up
all set up or or stories that conclude
but not with any particularly quotable
elements that's where I'm that's that's
my jam I'm just saying we could have
really reacted with pure laughter at
that joke
if it wasn't interrupted in the middle
of it I know and that's gonna haunt me
I'm gonna go home and I'm just gonna
think of what were they say I'll never
have a way of finding out what they said
it ruined my week I know it's ruined my
weekend really like preemptively I'm not
gonna feel good anymore this weekend I
just know that come Monday I'll be like
God what did I do I needed that laugh I
know that joke all you needed was one
more and I took that away from us and
the viewers at home and the writers and
the cast of the show I would love it if
the highlights come back and they didn't
include that moment
I was like what are you guys talking
about what are you guys referring to
right now this will be the true test do
the editors watch the review
there's no point for them to do so
otherwise why would we give notes
something
uh times like we talked about this in
review
bring back this moment yeah say whatever
we want about them they're not going to
hear it ain't that right yeah right
[ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] is a prepper
one of them is a Woman except for you
you're just a regular jerk
call a woman a [ __ ] I didn't I called
exclusively the men [ __ ] yeah but not
in a way that suggests that forget it
I'm not going to explain the joke they
have a sense of humor
[Music]
um but yeah this has been good Arc I
hope I don't expect it necessarily but I
hope Adrian pimento shows up one more
time
maybe if they Crack the Case I hope he
dies on camera yes violently like in a
moment where they're like we had to rate
this episode higher than we normally do
just have to have like a warning
disclaimer at the beginning of it
parental discretion is advised they
should do like a really serious episode
like one serious cop drama episode no
humor whatsoever
like the Fresh Prince reboot yes that's
everyone loved that Fresh Prince we
should do Brooklyn nine they should
reboot Brooklyn Nine-Nine but as a super
serious half hour cop show totally
straight never been done before yeah
I've never done a crime drama cop show
in New York why haven't they done that
they are you know they're behind
Hollywood's running out of ideas and yet
they got a golden one right there that
they could use for the first time and
they just don't want it could have
several shows about the the people in
blue and the NYPD
shows who investigate crime scenes all
that stuff yeah you could have several
kinds of that show you too you know they
really I don't get why they don't do it
there's no shortage of crimes
to rip from the headlines
dumbasses they could only depict law as
well as order did you see Evan Peters is
playing Jeffrey Dahmer in the Ryan
Murphy Netflix movie I at least I I
haven't seen any footage but I heard the
information and I thought to myself
maybe this time they'll make a good true
serial killer story movie
Maybe
the amount of serial killers real life
ones they've brought to life on American
Horror Story and the amount of crazy
killers and cold people that
Evan Peters has played brilliantly I'm
like like this is the one this is the
one you wanted to tell Dahmer doesn't
mean it feels like this could have been
part of your American Horror Stories
they could have done like an American
Horror Stories where every episode is a
different serial killer
biography
yeah I'm with that pulpy zanyness and
loudness that Ryan Murphy likes yeah man
that's the place for that kind of story
you gotta when we get them playing Ted
buddy the whole 80s one had Richard
Ramirez in the whole time oh really cool
well maybe I'll watch it cool he was a
great guy I love that nice Soccer Boy
good thing give it to me let's do uh
yeah who else do we got let's get Albert
Fish let's do it let's let's do Lizzie
Borden on American Horror Story happens
to uh
anyway we're losing track zodiac guys
this was another funny episode another
great installment excited for the last
one yeah next week
it's right
sayonara Patron
Chris Wham off ah Chris you're in for it
we looked up your name on Urban
Dictionary because we we can't we just
can't Define you properly so we wanted
to find a definition that truly defines
you the hottest guy you will ever meet
his abs are nothing compared to his hair
humor and looks guy is a hundred out of
ten he is so sexy so sexy so kind Chris
is always there for a friend no matter
what but he is also there to make about
person laugh
Chris also can't really write
um unfortunately okay when you're that
sexy you don't need to have
grammatically perfect sentences his hair
will always be on point that hair is
just so striking you ask for tips the
womb hair and so will his looks and abs
he really likes to emphasize his
physical appearance any girls is lucky
to have him look in her direction if
he's yours you better keep him because
in bed or anywhere he will rock your
world dude this is where all of your
pride and ego has gone to this one entry
this is where all those acts of kindness
go Chris wamoth I knew you had to be I
knew you had to have some kind of
self-love in there buddy you can't just
beat Mr generous completely selfless or
Nothing Like You Gotta give to your abs
hair and your sexy good looks
not only is he hot he's charitable he's
charitable charity hot
hottable Bowl hot
I can't think when I'm around you Chris
or talking about talk
Chris thank you for being here you rock
buddy
[Music]